number number
five it starts like this and then like
this or it can just go straight from
here to there and this one you step at
your level don't worry but I expect that
the seniors you anybody wearing a
hackimer or black belt to get this
toe
moving
like
that
he so your body starts to become as one
do your best the fist the buy when you
get up here just turn and everybody turn
go the other
way
try to feel it more Co feel it more
sense it sense it feel it you're s doing
the action but you're not experiencing
the the whole thing experience the whole
thing I it try to experience it what
you're doing
don't just don't just do it try and feel
what
it it's
like uh move down a little bit please
okay well as a beginner you have it get
you can open your hands when you get
higher grade but as a beginner you have
to get your hands closed cuz that what
that does is that tightens up your body
so you don't get too many see like this
you can make lots of mistakes but if you
keep this you got to sort of like get
everything correct and you'll feel like
you're what I call in a box you'll feel
like you're boxed in and you haven't got
a lot of freedom but